gilles lellouche bonsoir voir dont vous
êtes ici ce soir pour un livre un livre
bouleversant
non je ne suis pas le fils de claude
lelouch
ah oui sur la difficulté de l'homonymie
dans notre société ça c'est pas vrai
mais c'est toujours se faire un prénom
même temps quand tu t'appelles lellouche
en plus s'appelle gilles c'est vrai que
je connais pas une star dans le monde
qui s'appelle gilles en fait gilberto
gil oui donc c'est pas son prénom est
marina bay avec un québécois avec une
coupe sa probable agile comme il
s'appelait gilles vigneault
oui
bien sûr la maison et donc gilles et
acteur dans le film de klapisch qui
s'appelle paris qu'un film excellent
alors je me dis comme ça faut aller le
voir vous allez voir le casting cas dans
ce film juliette binoche romain duris
françois cluzet fabrice luchini albert
dupontel karin viard julie ferrier
mélanie laurent zinedine soualem audrey
marnay et gilles lellouche voilà
alors le pitch est lumineux c'est très
simple c'est l'histoire d'un parisien
qui est malade et qui se demande s'il va
mourir et son état lui donne un regard
neuf sur les gens qu'il croise et quand
on sort du film on est heureux parce
qu'on se dit dans le fond pourquoi je
regarde pas tout le temps le monde comme
si j'allais mourir donc c'est un film
qui est très émouvant qui rend heureux
qui est super bien fait en plus c'est un
film choral donc c'est ainsi 8 destin
des gens qui se croisent dans la ville
dans paris comme ça s'est super bien
fait il brosse plusieurs portraits que
ce soit la rive droite la rive gauche
les gens qui se couchent tard les gens
qui se les fronts moi par exemple je
joue un poissonnier qui est un peu un qi
de parquet
très viril un très riche et moins
houleux testostérone wii qui est
amoureux du personnage de julie ferrier
qui est l'ex femme de d'albert dupontel
et moi je suis finalement amoureux
d'elle mais j'ai une drôle de façon de
lui dire voilà et c'est très juste moi
je trouve qu'il ya des scènes comme ça
dans le film de cédric qui me font
penser à ce que vous pouvez faire claude
sautet à sa meilleure période où
lellouche ouais quand il faisait du bon
cinéma est vraiment son film est
vraiment extrêmement touchant et très
humain très altruiste
effectivement c'est un carpediem simple
voilà c'était c'est une leçon de vie le
signe d'ailleurs quand on sort de là moi
j'étais vraiment ému bouleversé en même
temps j'étais content parce que je me
disais n'attend pas d'être malade pour
regarder le monde comme ça
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
mercredi dans la newsletter du nouvel
observateur la place d'henri salvador on
aurait annoncé la mort de salvador dali
vrai c'est vrai mais ils sont bien
ça a duré 18 secondes un coup et aurait
été contacté pour jouer françois
hollande dans l'adaptation de l'avis de
ségolène royal
on est 25 ans de thriller michael
jackson aurait sorti un nouveau remix de
son visage
alors pour justifier le choix de la
nouvelle couleur du maillot des bleus
qui joue désormais en rouge à
l'extérieur adidas aurait produit une
étude prouvant qu'une équipe joue en
rouge avait plus de chances de gagner
qu'une autre c'est possible vrai c'est
vrai ça marcherait tout le temps tu
regardes les communistes
non mais manchester
liverpool le milan ac sont au rouge
les maillots il ferait d'un portage et
ouais c'est ça en fait carla bruni
aurait confié une amie oui on vit une
mauvaise passe avec nicolas mais c'est
normal c'est la crise des deux semaines
mais attention le plus vraiment après
tout ce temps
ça existe à la cause des décès je veux
en parler
lui aurait déclaré je n'ai pas envie de
participer à la star academy plutôt
mourir je trouve que c'est une émission
pathétique rumeurs parues marc sebbah
rumeurs mais pourquoi les partis affalé
sur m6 la vraie je voulais l'a fait elle
a fait d'astarac complet se voit donc
c'est des conneries
lors du dernier prime de la star ac hier
soir pas s'ils s'en serait pris à pascal
[ __ ] en exigeant qu'ils changent de nom
pendant son voyage en guyane nicolas
sarkozy aurait demandé à voir le lieu de
tournage de la première compagnie
ce sont là que des allégations
par ailleurs la déviation
allégations ont corroboré
enfin préparer un remake du film les
oiseaux de hitchcock avec ingrid chauvin
intitulé les corps gras et j'ai lu ça
mais c'est un faux nom
évoque les pigeons les pigeons aussi de
ceux qui regardent les paiements la
première imprimante en 3d qui fabrique
des objets viendrait de sortir
n'importe quoi non et c'est vrai c'est
dans le parisien elle fabrique des
objets de 12 centimètres cube pour 5000
dollars c'est ce que tu voyais à star
trek en les appuie sur le bouton il faut
lui l'a dit c'est exactement bravo ainsi
c'est ce qu'on venait dans star trek
suite à ses victoires aux grammy awards
amy whinehouse aurait tenus à
personnellement remercier la drogue et
l'alcool sans lesquels elle ne serait
jamais arrivé
les moeurs
toi ces allégations françois fillon
aurait demandé à nicolas sarkozy de
partir en voyage de noces pour six mois
lui a demandé à simon apparemment en
fait il que la sarkozy aurait cédé
devant les chauffeurs de taxi en échange
de la promesse de mettre les grosses
têtes moins fort à l'arrière
dans l'huile et vivait n'en produirait
de l'électricité
avec de la graisse de porc et des
déchets d'andouille
c'est un coin ces
accidents du travail en afghanistan un
kamikaze qui partit se faire sauter lors
de l'inauguration d'une mosquée auraient
raté une marche son descendant
l'escalier de chez lui et serait mort
explosé possible possible
c'est possible par ippon
ça prouve bien pour la paix organisé le
11 septembre n'est pas à s'organiser
pour
d'après le site du nouvel obs le soir du
second tour nicolas sarkozy a envoyé un
sms et ségolène royal 10 ans j'étais
bien [ __ ]
faudel aurait tenté de se suicider deux
fois après cette pesée par humeur
on viendrait de sortir le guide du
routard de la création d'entreprise oui
c'est vrai j'ai vu que brice hortefeux
et sortir le guide du routard de comment
rentrer dans ton pays
dimanche dernier après la mort de ron
scheider près de 250 requin blanc aurait
été un très corsé
pour justifier
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu